[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you fools
you're back again
welcome back to the break room our daily
show that keeps you updated on just
what's going on the nerd news from our
very own break room oh baby
coming up we're gonna talk a little
multiverse madness baby
batman i'm buried coming for that number
one spot
[Applause]
oh we got dark man news dark man news
1992. i just want to interrupt real
quick and let it be known that
ludacris voice was written into the
teleprompter okay so what time he just
did wasn't required but tommy wrote this
what about in the library but you can't
be too loud you want to make another beg
for it give me tlc
all right dark man news uh because i
guess the show has become a time machine
uh and we got some multiverse visitors
who's knocking
all right let's meet our hosts today
my brother from the very same mother
biologically zack huddleston
bill's
oh mafia gosh uh
uh my brother from a very different
mother brandon bear
hello
different moms different
my sister from the game twister jessica
clements
left hand red
and my daddy who also works is my caddy
on the golf course
now
man i'm full of a lot of shame about how
all this went
very quickly shame is just a code word
for us anyway uh let's talk about the uh
incentives today we're throwing the
swear jar out that can go [ __ ] itself
uh no
you can't just curse more oh sorry
my bad
today's incentive is amazing if you use
the exclamation point tip prompt we are
going to introduce a multiverse version
of ourselves ripping through the
multiverse we need 50 in the tip jar and
you'll get to meet those multiverse
personas so if you want to see what the
multiverse has to offer for the break
room cast
you got to hit that tip jar guys i can't
stress that enough uh phillip hi
i'm i'm uh so in awe of the fact that
apparently you guys have done this for
an entire week yeah so far day five week
one good we feel alive only two of you
clapped
so that's all the only ones that are
that's the kind of rapport i clapped my
cheeks you just couldn't see them
i felt it oh
my god
that did make a
very audible sound
it was like a crunching of a spine
tommy's butt
butt cam please they got to pay a lot
more for the ass yeah yeah yeah oh you
guys that turned into my groin cam yeah
i'm uh i can head to my link tree if you
want to see my butt okay is this what
you guys do i have not watched an
episode of the show
oh i heard i'm in boston you took over
the break room and i heard people could
not eat lunch in here yeah complaining
yeah uh our director john tried to have
a ham sandwich here the other day and i
slapped it out of his hand yeah
yeah and then uh yeah you know we had
content to make yeah that's great uh
well i'm very proud of you guys for what
you're uh doing here and the fact that
you took it upon yourselves and you made
this thing your own i think it's you
know people are still like what is this
a little bit yes and i think that's fine
because you know we're never doing it
again
i think no it's been it's been great you
know uh uh i said it was an experiment
to you guys uh but so was the manhattan
project so you know that was the bomb
okay uh uh they had explosive results uh
no no i love i love that you guys are
doing this and i loved uh seeing some
new faces on camera too and also
everybody helping eric have less to do
is very important we're trying to
i want to mention just to keep everybody
who has not seen doctor strange yet we
are going to keep this show spoil-free
yes drama-free nope uh high fructose
corn syrup fruits free of any additives
and let it be known folks in the chat we
appreciate you chatting sending in super
chats all of that let's keep the
spoilers out of the chat we're assuming
maybe a lot of you have already seen the
movie but probably a lot of you haven't
yet monday monday's episode of the break
room that's right spoilers are plenty
and everything goes right
all right but for today you killed
kennedy that's right
moon reel this is both the same answer
the band yes
today um today we will be keeping it
spoiler free though all five of us have
seen it yes uh four of us saw it last
night and then philip you got to go to a
premiere yeah a premiere yeah was it a
or the i don't know
a long hallway uh
tommy got me tickets and uh
my organs uh oh yeah recover you met my
friend gargash
that's the same guy who helped us with
door decks yeah
wow
he runs premier screenings now yes no i
did get to thanks uh so much to the kind
people at disney and marvel that they've
been like inviting us to things like
that eric's going to go to star wars
celebration
like a lot of legit stuff's happening
but that premiere experience was amazing
i absolutely like took pictures with
people that i don't think i was supposed
to approach you know but i have a
picture just of me and elizabeth olsen
and looking back at it i'm like my hand
is on her back yeah whoa
how do i
live up to that any other time in my
life did i give you free food uh no okay
but at the eternals premiere they did
have cookies
all right i'll go on about the cookies
wookie cookies uh no it was the eternals
premiere not everything rhymes in life
they're gonna be uh let's hear george's
thena snack cake that lego gamer just
said why does zach dress as shaggy from
scooby-doo
that was the first thing i said when i
entered the rut
scooby rose
yeah uh hashtags could be roasted
jessica pointed it out earlier uh it was
purely unintentional but you know hey if
you got crimes to solve
we gotta get out of here
but uh thank you uh thank you pretty
cyber that's right whoever said that
lego gamer but now philip uh i did
follow along on social media your
adventures at the premiere outfit looked
great looked like a very cool thing now
what's the difference you think it's
obviously you've watched a lot of movies
not at a premiere what changes about
your viewing experience when you know
you're there with the stars and the
makers of the film uh it is
um definitely a more like energetic
electric room because everybody is like
no one's going to go like boo
boo the actor who's over there but also
so many people at the premieres worked
on the movie in some way or another that
you can see pride like when you sit
through the credits section every chunk
you just hear like a different part of
the premier uh audience just go nuts wow
so it like it that room is very much
feeling like a celebration of a thing
that they achieved kind of like you guys
here at the end of the week you know all
this came together and the way you guys
watch your own show back and you guys
just laugh you're all your own jokes and
applause
is being at the premiere is it just like
constantly like the leo meme like oh
yeah
well there's two ways to do it i gotta
stop everyone
we've already hit oh
variant multiverse stars oh this is
already it says zack swap but i believe
we're doing we chose i thought we chose
everybody okay everybody's gonna swap
okay they're variants okay we'll we'll
keep talking to philip so that they we
can't show you how you're in on
philadelphia open up the portals that's
right all right oh i'm disappearing
keep talking about the premiere and uh
so at the premiere uh one there's two
ways to do it uh one is where you are
very casually trying to approach um some
celebrities and hopefully get to stand
next to them get a picture and then the
other way is people scream their names
constantly and they also scream like
their nicknames because they're big fans
so elizabeth olsen you just hear
constant lizzy lizzy lizzy that was eric
that was doing that uh the entire time
uh uh still vamping uh also i went um
and i tried to do interviews and the
only ones i could get were spanish
language interviews
so being able to uh rehearse my marvel
language uh spanish stuff and try to
talk about uh what a celeste celestial
in spanish was a very difficult but also
very rewarding for also uh america
travis is our first uh latin x uh
character uh a superhero named i was
very excited to see her and i got to
meet her and also meet all of you
that sounds lit fam just want to give a
shout out to everybody at the tom squad
all my brothers and sisters in the hype
house we keep it right we keep it tight
we keep the content coming day and night
well you're at the premiere do they give
you free drinks or free popcorn or
anything uh they give you free drinks
and free popcorn what is your variant
brandon i'm from a time a universe where
everyone
can't see the sun
gotcha similar to ours but we also
shouldn't stare at the sun no you can
see your sun like we can't see ourselves
oh like the sun's invisible yeah
and well you're just a snark
france won world war ii
who were good friends it was france
against everyone yeah yeah yeah they won
we all wear berets we all have fart
scented masks so we can sniff our own
fuss all day
make them clap it's so lit
you wouldn't believe it is that is that
really what your variance difference is
this is just
your fault i'm an influencer with the
fart mask okay
[Laughter]
all right guys i'm not a very i don't
know how to travel through any different
dimensions it's just me i do like that
you curled your hair for it uh same old
boy
i noticed also different hair over here
but also is there any other difference
um i'm the jessica that steals
oh
so i'm constantly pick pocketing oh wait
a second whoa it kind of looks like i
have more things in my pocket it kind of
looks like we have a shaggy and now
daphne now we got daphne
[Laughter]
is anybody surprised that tommy shows up
to work with a bag of props
he's been
if you're asking where my other six arms
are
they're in my pants oh god we haven't
even got to the headlines that's right
uh actually i i don't want to be part of
this anymore uh i haven't i have a
meeting to get to uh but honestly i'm so
proud of you guys you guys are so great
you guys are killing it i love working
with these people every day and that was
a big part of uh why uh they we did this
show was so you guys could feel the
vibes of like what it's like to work
with these people every day and you know
now you have to suffer it too yeah and
uh but good job guys and you'll be back
phillip oh we'll see we hope you get to
watch the show someday yeah
you know i'm busy put it on your
calendar goodbye
[Music]
break your chair break your chair
i am lord of the office now
i am king
i am conqueror
i am he who remains oh speaking of he
who remains we've got some headlines to
talk about today
what's the headline oh in this universe
we have headlines
what do you guys have feet lines oh by
the way thank you everyone for all of
your chat donations everyone has been
very generous so yeah
sorry i didn't mean to interrupt the
headlines i'm just so overwhelmed with
the generosity we got like two you guys
are avoiding the spoilers and you guys
are spoiling us like a couple of brats
like a couple of bratz i'm gonna miss my
dinner uh well here's our first headline
for today ewan mcgregor mentioned on
kimmel uh he said something very
interesting about how the video games of
star wars and the movies are going to
come together he said quote you can't
have some fact in the video game that
doesn't match up with the movie oh
so i mean a big departure from how the
mario brothers movie yeah like the mario
brothers universe dennis hopper had no
clue no clue no clue he's like what if
this is based on a video game
yeah yeah right what is this so i think
the most exciting thing for all of us
right is this means that there could be
some fallen order story lines that
make sense in the movie story lines
right the the stuff we know about the
inquisition in this series yeah yeah uh
the stuff we know about the inquisitors
from like fallen order could show up uh
on the obi-wan show could calcus show up
on the obi-wan show
dadson would go crazy if calculated uh
don't lose his mind sure he would lose
his johnson's in the chat right now
dawson just donated three thousand
dollars
uh batman unburied uh this this is the
audio series of alabama yes this is on a
spotify batman series uh i have some
more to say about it but yeah
it just knocked the joe rogan experience
from its top spot on spotify which is
pretty crazy to think about like uh an
audio podcast about batman knocking off
the most popular narrative i guess so
what i was going to say about it is
we're going to be covering this on the
channel oh no eric has a breakdown of
the first episode of this podcast series
i think coming out next week wow made in
conjunction with spotify the cast of
this the the boys is nuts winston duke
who played embarco in uh black panther
and um uh a bunch of like vance reddick
lance reddick
recognized from the wire and bosch
jonathan reese uh
myers from lord of the rings anyways
[Laughter]
[Applause]
not that hard uh so i i need somebody's
mic though okay so i uh got i just came
back yesterday from new york where i got
to go to a batman on buried private
dinner
uh which was insane you can see you can
follow along on my instagram but
[Laughter]
but uh the the craziest thing about it
so in the story there's a character
called the harvester yeah and that is
the villain of the story uh he's been
murdering people so what they did is
they served us a dinner
that kind of and like like if you listen
to the first episode you hear kind of
like an autopsy is being performed and
bruce wayne is a little different than
traditional bruce wayne in it he's
actually a doctor and
he uh they talk all about these organs
or whatnot and then they serve us four
courses that resemble oregon
it was actual organs this is hannibal
and it was it was actual organs uh and i
have a taste for human flesh now
[Applause]
he undocked that is just like hannibal
the show with the mads mikkelsen uh that
was like my favorite thing about that
show hamill had dinner parties all the
time and you didn't know as the audience
if they were eating animals or people i
love a soiree
wear meats on the menu
tommy teased it earlier sam raimi said
universal is talking about a dark man
sequel
and there's a producer attached so you
know what's going to happen most
definitely what is dark man that's what
jessica said and i'm sure a lot of you
young folks out there in the chat are
like what the hell if you're my age dark
man is the first movie to traumatize yes
it was a movie that came out in 1990 uh
sam raimi made it he wrote it uh he won
because he wanted to make all these like
superhero movies like he didn't get to
do the shadow he didn't get to do batman
he's like i'm going to make my own
superhero yeah it's about the uh liam
neeson stars in it was like his first
kind of action movie uh and he's this
guy who gets like severely burned and
like heals himself but like also he's
crazy yeah it it and it's very creamy
he's got some poorer elements some kind
of lace-up a lot of body horror spawned
a bunch of direct to dvds right
i think maybe one theatrical sequel yeah
yeah but i think there's like four dark
man movies
i also i was um reading an interview
they uncovered with bill paxton recently
when they were just they've been
covering a lot of sam raimi press
recently of actors sure sure i would
like to work with him in the late great
bill pecks one of my favorite actors of
all time mentioned that he was actually
in final talks to play dark man and then
he was good friends with liam neeson and
they were talking about like what's
going on in their careers and their
lives and he told liam neeson about this
role and liam neeson called sam raimi
and got the dirty job
he's got a very special set of skills
that's right stealing your role i would
guess i would say that role was taken
mr steal your role
girl
hey hey hey oh that's a pretty nice roll
you got there yeah oh
somebody took it it would be ashamed to
lose it uh dwayne johnson uh you might
know him as the rock i know him as the
people's champion
he shared a photo from the black adam
set let's take a look at that photo oh
this is a behind-the-scenes photo i take
looking yolks i don't think that's his
outfit
jim shorts at the job was this mocap we
think maybe is that why he's in normal
looking clothes he said that it was
reshoot oh so it could possibly be he's
not missing arm damage maybe maybe he's
a generous actor who he's not even in
these reshoots but he's there just as
just pierce brockton is a generous actor
more than it's joining the wrong johnson
as like the producer for oh sure because
he does the same thing for fast and
furious so he definitely
behind the tp like
[Music]
speaking of photos we got a new image
it's a couple new images from the thor
love and thunder set uh uh john will pop
those up for us oh look at that
beautiful boy
looking great
yeah heavy heavy big trouble little
china vibes right kurt russell's kind of
outfit in that the tucked in white shirt
looking good i like like the hairstyle
might have to steal it and also a very
fantasy background oh yeah right very
playing into the fantasy trope is that
photo before or after you know what i'm
saying before or after because he's like
that we see well this is what it's been
thought of what i'm thinking what's
happening he's debating on even being a
superhero right now right he's thinking
about retiring is this at the beginning
of the film
i think that's like the beginning right
yeah don't don't you get the sense that
we haven't seen anything from the second
half of that movie yet yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah i wonder if the
guardians are even going to be in the
second half yeah maybe they're just kind
of in the opening yeah
yeah they got their own movies they got
other work to do i agree uh in a little
moonlight news uh it turns out it was
kevin feige's idea to put that rip in uh
mr knight's mask that's right a little
tear in there oh what a great little
idea i feel like there's all these
little stories come out post things like
kevin feige has this great idea just
imagine kevin fighting showing up the
set and then being like let me try
okay
he's like uh so that happens
it's like a six and seven eighths kevin
feige he's like seven and three get
was that the only moon knight news that
we had no we did have a little more moon
night what else was there why is this
midnight news even important if you were
tuned in to the show yesterday and we
know you all were thank you so much you
saw that tommy's uh moon knight
predictions he didn't do well no uh and
it resulted in him having the worst
night of my life being forced to tweet
something out that jessica had uh
commanded him to tweet yeah he was
jessica's avatar yes uh it involved feet
uh thank you all for sending in those
lovely pictures
we learned this today uh there was a
scrapped cameo for moon knight oh it was
going to involve the eternals oh it was
specific
well it was specifically going to have
camille's
show up in an ancient egypt flashback
because he likes to pile around with
gods he talked about hanging out with
him
and maybe three or four other eternals
but the the massive cost
the main reason for its removal poor
tommy you know the worst part is you
could have easily been right if they
just got a little bit more money will
you look and i say i got expensive case
baby yeah i don't know what to tell you
um
this is a little news item from
yesterday that we missed chris pratt was
on the today show and he was talking
about jurassic world dominion which is
coming out and he was saying that this
could be the last film in the franchise
it was kind of saying it pretty
definitively this is what he said this
is a quote this is the finale i feel
like the whole movie is that and it's
like 30 years in the making this is the
sixth jurassic film and it's the end of
the franchise
i really do think it's the end you were
saying that because he was he was making
this metaphor it feels like the end of a
fireworks show sure because goldblum and
laura
sam neil are coming back yeah so i mean
it's not up to chris yeah if they want
to make more movies they're going to
make more movies and as long as
universal can get some dollars out of
that franchise you they're probably
going to keep making more but john and i
were kind of bouncing this around like
it's a very
i see this franchise
you either have dinosaurs or you don't
have dinosaurs yes yeah so what's the
answer yeah you're right we're we're
kind of running out of uh fossil fuels i
think it's gonna be one of those things
that happened like 30 years from now
they could do a time jump that would be
fun someone's going to be like we need
to touch this on this again go back
go back to the 1920s and have
people pass towards discover dinosaurs
instead of vaccines periods jurassic
park i got my times line timelines are
mixed up there uh and then finally uh
doctor strange is already off to a fiery
start in his multiverse of madness he
brought in 86 million internationally in
just two days and it's not even finished
not even three days
two days
internationally already 86. and that's a
nice transition and again for folks just
now joining us or who joined us after we
began today we're going to be a
spoiler-free discussion of multiverse
and madness we've all seen the movie
we're gonna try our best not to spoil it
please do the same in the chat and with
the questions you're supposed to us
don't spoil it yes uh so we wanna field
your your super chats your questions in
the chat we'll be we'll be answering as
many as possible that we've got to tread
that fine line of trying not to spoil
the movie for people that haven't seen
it yet yeah um
great so oh and also i wanted to shout
out shout out to a couple people that
recognized this last night at this point
yes you took up your ass you took a
photo with a young man who recognized
tommy from the channel i just said his
name out loud his mother probably
doesn't appreciate it well you can say
his last day well you could have said
that that was a fake name you just gave
but now you can it was his real name and
he's loving it if he's watching right
now yes and then shout out we didn't get
this guy's name but shout out to the
gentleman who stuck his head out of a
restaurant window while we were walking
by and screamed new new rock stars f and
rocks yes and i must say as a reminder
if you see me in public you better come
approach me because it makes everyone
i'm with very impressed
yes
uh so oh so but along those lines hey we
want to shout out also our friends at
the epic hero shop uh purveyors of great
merch
none of us are wearing right now but
every other day this week we've been
rocking it to the time uh yep you can
get that tie at the epic hero shop
and you can get rid of me this is their
latest item
a multiverse of madness latest obsession
shirt throw that beautiful shirt up
there
look at that so now for folks that don't
know the latest obsession series is a
limited edition set of t-shirts they
release one per big property for your
loki for your falcon winter soldier for
your eternals and now for multiverse of
madness there are folks out there that
have collected all of these they're
numbered as to the one in the series
it's only a set number of these shirts
grab one for yourself uh that's a cool
design inspired by multiverse of madness
um yeah and check out all the other
great products we've got at the epic
hero shop to be fair i am wearing the uh
moon knight thong but
that's a waning gibbous oh baby
we're not going to show that i can't
confirm this but i did hear that if ever
the people who own every uh latest
obsession shirt they've retired from
what i hear yeah i can't confirm it
yeah they they're so valuable yeah
like on the the the accumulated wealth
of their latest subjects they're able to
they're able to take out insurance
policies two or three million dollars
you walk into the bank with all your
lace obsession shirts they give you
whatever you want my only regret is that
you can't wear them all at the same time
yeah yeah uh okay let's transition now
into that title that thumbnail topic
multiverse of madness
uh we all saw it last night yes uh we've
got some strong thoughts again we're
gonna do our best to talk about the
movie while tucking around the movie
we're not gonna give away any big plot
points i think we're gonna assume it's
fair game to discuss anything that was
revealed in a trailer
okay so professor x charles xavier uh
patrick stewart yeah that was widely
publicized for months uh in trailers so
we can talk about that is that the
premiere we won't yeah we won't reveal
other important key plot details that
were not in the trailer uh well first
hit thoughts big takeaways your your
general reactions oof baby i think i was
most excited
because i don't know much about her was
america shaw visit and the actress
playing her
blown away i'm upset i thought she was
fine i'm obsessed i was like this is the
icon that i want for my children also i
was so impressed like reading like she
was like 14 and 15 when she shot this
movie oh my gosh yeah she's only like 16
now which like the gravitas the like
performance with you know she's with
bender cumberbatch and elizabeth olsen
in a lot of these scenes and she totally
holds her own she's really good at
holding her own especially as someone
that was like yeah you're with benedict
cumberbatch and elizabeth olsen it's
like i know you guys but you don't know
me yeah she did very good holding her
own i'm obsessed with her i can't wait
to see where that actress goes and i'm
so happy she has like a home and i don't
think it's spoiling anything where that
character might go yeah yeah no exactly
100 well tough for her to go anywhere
when she burst into flames at the end
just kidding fake spoiler hashtag fake
spoiler uh
i really liked the way the movie looked
yes it looked very different and if you
if i was in a coma for 10 years and i
woke up and the first thing i saw was
was this movie i'd be like did sam
raymond direct this yes because they
love we swear we speak
mistakes we spent 10 minutes right after
it ended just talking about that yes
which is nice because i think you know
sometimes it can feel like all these the
marvel movies kind of all look the same
they're painting with the same colors
this felt like very different and i
really i really did like that about the
movie and then along i think you and i
had very similar kind of takeaways from
the movie for me the classic kind of
from spider-man 1 all the way to this
movie the zooming close-up sam raimi
camera angles camera work where you're
like is he about to smash into one of
these like whoever the director of
photography is i don't know if he dp's
his own movies like uh steven steven
soderbergh does but like i assume he's
right there being like all right get in
real fast and ah that absolutely
visually right there are some shots that
you could totally picture being in an
evil dead movie and drag me to hell a
dark man if you will um also the tone
was very rainy right leading into the
horror some some gross out stuff some
kind of body horror also the type of
humor in this movie
there is a lot of humor it's a
completely different breed of humor than
like a taika ytt
type of humor a um a shane black iron
man 3 kind of a humor right like he
definitely has his own kind of it's
campy it's very physical almost slap
sticky right like uh
les le there's certainly some fun lines
in this movie some quips but but
less of those much more of the like
physical kind of humor right and we for
sure got
our first i think really good depiction
of an omega level
powered individual in wanda like really
really well yeah we really got like the
omega
we can't say mutant well now we probably
can but like you know in the comics
there's the certain like top-tier
mutants that are like if it comes down
to it these are the ones that you do not
f with yeah yeah uh and i thought that
that was really well really well
established and i also still like this
this was a doctor strange movie yeah you
know i think that gets lost sometimes uh
with all the trailers and oh look who's
in it look who's in it look who's in it
and i kind of got worried that you know
dr strange would not good enough this is
a really good story for him uh i i love
what it did with his character i love
what it showed me
uh gave me a new newfound respect for
them and in a great acting
showcase
both both for him and elizabeth olsen
got to do a lot in this movie as far as
acting portraying a range of emotions
and characters and things like that they
both got like you could make a pretty
nice acting sizzle reel off of uh their
performance and god knows they're gonna
need it you know
they need the work but they need that
their phones are gonna be rigging for
auditions but that doesn't guarantee
bookings guys let me tell you i know
okay it's hard you gotta go in and read
and then the producer's gotta talk it
over and then they call you now i want
to talk about some uh some logistics
here okay
if somebody is going to see this movie
this weekend they're thinking about
getting a soda
okay
how should they
plan
their bathroom trips can they make it is
this movie so long that there's no way
you can make it without a bathroom trip
for me it didn't feel long no i like
that it doesn't feel long at all and i
think it's because
it just had so much happening that i was
like there's not one down i did uh as uh
as our one of our great researchers anna
pointed out i did my little teeny tiny
bladder didn't trade me and i did have
to go do a little you had to go like 10
minutes well to be fair i had three
drinks before
so
that might have been my bad doctor
wasn't the only one feeling strange if
you know what i'm saying i i i think you
gotta try and hold out i i did have to
run to the bathroom and i was i
regretted it i will say there's a
there's a scene just if you're thinking
if you're kind of like me and you never
want to miss anything good so you end up
holding it
to an unhealthy point in the movie okay
yeah a couple scenes i was thinking
about that are roughly halfway through
that might be a good scene where if you
can get in and out in about two minutes
you won't miss too much when
uh doctor strange and america chavez i
don't think this is a spoiler of any
kind
land in a place with lots of flowers
okay okay like a a world with lots of
greenery a location stay in a location
with spoilers okay fair okay when
they're on a city street with lots of
flowers and people in funky costumes i
think you've got a 90-second window okay
where you won't miss too much if right
then you need to run your house
very important funky funky costumes
confirmation
let me put it to you this way you go in
with a bone dry bladder
you'll make it through this film but you
got a wet bladder
you're going to have to blast some
people i think and i think i think you
can skip you can skip the avatar 2
trailer yeah oh my gosh it gives away
nothing i timed it perfectly i had to go
see that
at 6 10 and i left at 6 10. got there at
6 20
like right
when that trailer was ending and i was
like
whoo still had to watch
nicole goodman do not miss
the minions rise of crew trailer
they don't give enough away they get you
just hungry enough it's too much
maintenance not enough groove that's
something drew confirmed um we can spoil
that movie yes
yeah real quick the trailers we got i
don't know if these trailers everybody
will get we did get a top gun maverick i
feel like that was a trailer we've
already seen yeah
yeah store trailer was the same i had
seen the crew i feel like it was a new
trailer for super pets
i don't think i'd seen all that footage
not the super pets the one with the bad
wolf that everyone's attracted no that's
the bad guys super pets is a dc film
starring the dwayne the rock jumps kevin
hart vanessa bay or natasha leone and
others
not that he's paying attention and then
you know the avatar trailer was new um
yeah it was an interesting trailer in
that there's not much plot it's
basically just a visuals demo which to
me i i think it was you or maybe it was
tommy pointed out i would love to see a
side by side i can't tell if they look
better are they better i don't know but
anyways we'll be covering avatar on the
channel we'll be talking about it here
other other big takeaways again without
spoiling and it's hard for us to talk
too much about this movie yeah
so i think we did such a great job i
kind of but we also need to show off our
oh yeah we have a lot of no contacts
yeah spoilers oh yes out of context okay
so our social media tyler has been doing
this on instagram and twitter lately
where after every episode of moon night
he would put up out of context spoilers
was just like random reference images
that kind of talk about the episode of
moon knight so we've done the same thing
here for multiverse and madness brandon
you want to start you want to show
yourself i'll do mine first okay this is
not this is a no contact spoiler if you
know you know
okay okay if you know you know
uh elsa our lovely uh coordinator sam
yeah
thank you sam she just peeked her head
when brandon showed up
out of her work um mine
um for those that get it if you know you
know if you don't you don't got some
string cheese here oh wow
kind of string a little diced up little
blue shredded shred okay and mine is a
direct spoiler if you know about the uh
uh obscure marvel hero pizza dollar man
uh he shows up
and uh does the little pizza queue one
of my one of my favorite parts of the
movie yes incredible yeah incredible it
was a great laugh we chuckled heartily
at that scene and then mine this is
gonna seem like a no duh but once you
see the movie it has a deeper meaning
whatever happened to predictability
milkman the paperboy evening tv
we're gonna hang this one up in the back
this one's going over there with them
yes and i'm hanging this one above my
bed uh
we do want to say
maybe this is something you could easily
google but two post credit scenes one
comes pretty fast one's all the way at
the end full post credit if again just
thinking about your bladders
if you had to skip that second one you
can i could i don't think you have time
between the first one yes maybe that's
the best part and told me that i had to
stay for the second one i didn't say i
texted him and i said hey how many post
credit scenes and he's like the second
one six
i mean the second one's a lot of fun but
it is not a big plot thing it will not
ex change your experience of the movie
i'll just say that zach's trying to
spoil this movie for y'all yeah
all right all right all right all right
we've done a great job of not spoiling
so let's
get out of here clean we want to read
some of uh some of the super chats you
guys have done cody wright said i'd pay
to see a live stream of tommy's life in
one of his variant forms disney plus
make it happen all you got to do is go
to tommy showers bring mayflowers.com
and you can see my whole life uh
from my bathroom camp
joe gilroy says how can i intern for you
while working from home in louisiana
well you know i have uh i have in-laws
in baton rouge so maybe i'll head down
there uh i think it might have also been
joe
gullery gallery it sounds like a
cajun-ish kind of name you know what joe
i like that move of you stay in
louisiana man the food there yeah such a
big fan best of both worlds
unfortunately we're not taking an
internship right now what are they known
for alfredo i don't know
[Applause]
we got denzie canty that's a fun name uh
where do you think we'll see strange
next okay we're gonna be very careful in
answering this a third solo movie maybe
a to be revealed title or maybe
something we know is coming like what if
season two i think there's a good chance
he's going to be in what if season two
yeah yeah
is it
at the very end it did say that this
character would return yeah
we'll return which they love to do at
the end and of course he will well i
guess that's a little bit of a spoiler
he's not dead he doesn't die in this
movie apologies if you were holding out
hope that he would yes for those of you
that are in that weird death cult
uh this one is for brandon oh
i can't tell you uh well well here
before we move on okay to answer
denzie's question without getting into
specifics yeah
is he going to show up in a solo film in
a disney plus series or maybe in a team
up or avengers type film
i say what if i would say a series i
think he could do a series
awesome and i don't know if you count
what if as a who i think we'll
definitely see
strange supreme and what if season two
uh but if you count that then he'll
definitely maybe maybe a one division
season two or this like
we're talking about the next one yeah
the very next question hasn't even been
that's true now
we know this like she-hulk series is
gonna maybe be a little funny and he's a
fun guy to be funny yeah it would be
good to have him as a character witness
or something like we call in the
sorcerer yeah when we think that's
what's in the second place in new york
right yeah i think it's gonna be in new
york he's down the street okay okay uh
jorge quiros says if you give i'll give
you another chance on my name i just i
clearly said it right i'll give you all
i'll take you all for drinks i got to
get better contacts if you come to costa
rica and he said he loved doctor strange
too yeah beautiful movie great
performances
and i mean if international fights were
cheaper my man we would take you up on
that horse see if there's a theater that
wants to have a live panel and we'll
come down there for some work you know
what we love our fans in costa rica and
jorge we love you the most okay uh
freight girl asked how many times will i
scream involuntarily like i did for matt
murdock i will say there's a lot of
screams in this movie yes
a lot of them in volunteering i saw it
by myself and i screamed a lot
these screams will have different
feelings behind there are i would say a
lot of screens three or four legit jump
scares yeah
it is a scary and like like you know
long moment of tension almost
halloween-esque right punctuated by a
jump scare you'll there'll be some
there'll also be some screams of delight
yeah there were several of those in our
theater is
moving wheels and this is a pg-13 just
like leaning up yeah it's the hard on
the 13th 13 and three quarters
a cigarette against the wall of an
r-rated movie i mean the 26 more you can
see in imax that might be an r i don't
know oh yeah well i mean jessica's the
only one that could you saw
and i'm not going to spoil it
all right guys we are you know it's
friday it's casual it's loose
we want to still take some more
questions from you guys they don't have
to be questions about doctor strange
this is a bit of an ama for us you guys
now we got some time ask us anything
about it i got a couple here okay jay
dino saying i say lizzy whenever i
whenever i see lizzie too
referring to philip uh mentioning that
all the paparazzi scream lizzie
i just think it's weird i've seen some
reporters
like they're talking about her and say
lizzy yeah and she's not in the room i
don't know i don't feel comfortable
that's like bob
yeah it's being like i'm good friends
with her i can call her lizzie he's like
she's not here
yeah you guys want to each name drop a
celebrity we consider a friend yeah yeah
uh
um
i mean dusty hoffman
oh oh oh we're making them up
i hang out with benjamin
yeah yeah that's right you love benny
um i hang out with um i just talked to
brandon about this i just found out my
friend is bruce campbell's son oh
bruce campbell junior yeah you just said
his name yeah david's bruce beetlejuice
beetlejuice um uh oh well off of
brandon's i have a good friend named um
matthew demon oh yeah
i know him okay we got a couple there
was a poll in chat 69 percent of chat
claims to have seen the film oh wow
that's great i mean it kind of makes
sense this is i i was keeping the movie
industry a lot and one of my favorite
topics is spoiler culture and or the
pushback against that and of course most
of the people that would click on a
doctor strange thumbnail the day the
movie comes out probably have seen the
movie yeah so but we're still being good
for the 39 that haven't don't worry um i
see some bad math there but that's right
this is a good one i think this is from
matt i might be misreading your name uh
how y'all think this movie pushes the mc
future
definitely keeping it in that spooky
magic world we are in a spooky magical
i think i think that's right on the
money like this phase i don't know if
they're doing phases anymore where we're
at right now yeah a lot of magic i think
everything leading up to end game was a
lot of science yeah i think they're
doing errors now as the kids say we're
in our chaos era this is like the cosmic
magic
and i will say so far
not laying groundworks
for a
uh an avengers level movie or event um
yes it doesn't seem like they're
building that up they probably are and
they're just not stating it but it's not
like 2023 we're getting
the next avengers movie i want to go
hard right turn here
okay chris
no last name given so i'm gonna have to
assume it's christopherson uh asks what
bounty hunters will we see go after
canoobie oh well i think we saw that
kind of like bug yeah
who was in the lineup the infamous
lineup yes uh in empire strikes back
could we see boba i mean it takes place
in the past
that would be they'd have to be a great
page
tomorrow
i guess you don't gotta see his face
okay in the background they could just
get it yeah it could literally just be
the helmet on i would love to never know
i would love to see ig-88 i mean yeah
ig-88 we kind of got that on a different
ig droid but i want to see the other
there's a shot of a droid in the trailer
right shooting a gun or something like
that i think that's the bug one the one
he's got
uh what else we got texas dad said did
you all have a good did y'all did you he
he's gonna all have a good crowd
well so i will say the theater we saw it
at uh downtown burbank 16 should not be
giving out that information
but um uh great crowd it was probably
showing on half the screens there they
had like a showing going every 15
minutes our theater was not packed it
wasn't like to capacity but it was
probably 80 i would say yeah did you
guys see the picture of the uh amc in
times square that had 60 showings of
doctor strange yesterday
60.
shout out to i mean i i will say the the
good and bad of like we're still kind of
coming out of pandemic movie going like
it's not like maybe summer would have
been five years ago where a huge
blockbuster came out two weeks ago we
got a huge blockbuster coming out next
week yeah everybody cleared out for
doctor strange okay they're like you can
have may my man you know we know we're
not making any money we did have a lot
of there were a lot of cosplayers around
our theater which was great to see they
saw some spider-man cosplayers okay
spider-man look here spider-man
cosplay all you wanted
i tried to dress up as wong and you guys
begged me not to
i just like doing the voice
come on
i'm kidding
it's not the voice um oh nehemiah bethea
saying wanda versus gene
i assume that's a jean grey afternoon
from barry oh god audrey winkler's
character
there is some uh settle down wanda i
mean speaking of omega level mutants
gene
oh oh big stance yeah i think that's
that's that if i assume you have gene
with the phoenix force
uh she's pretty powerful the the phoenix
versus the cosmic entity but i mean
wanda are truly
the way they
set wanda up in wanda vision was though
that was enough to be like oh she's the
most powerful yeah i think someone who
can affect reality so intensely yes
i think this portrayal of wanda
and like the oh with the hand i've seen
that before i don't know that i put that
together yeah um that's a great tattoo
sometimes
who else got ink you got it i have none
you got eggs no i'm bad just me and jess
yeah 12 tattoos i have three um
okay all right
for another save it we got to save it
for the show
you gotta make him pay for it
i went on
i was gonna say i think this is the best
this portrayal of wanda was better than
any film portrayal of gene yes oh yes no
offense to sophie turner no offense to
my mommy
famke you you really got me through it
and a lot of it is
they gave the character more to do that
actress more to do we've gotten more
screen time with her it's a great
portrayal okay now we're going to be
careful with this but dylan colley says
anything you didn't particularly like
about the movie
and i think we're going to say that like
we all liked this movie yeah but even a
movie you love even your favorite movie
you can you can quibble you can have
moments you didn't like as much i will
say this coming out of it
the one of the things i love about
marvel movies that i think they do
better than almost all other movies
particularly the recent ones is there
are those
oh hell yeah moments right often in the
big final fights that's thor with the
immigrant song kicking in when he's
fighting
at the end of ragnarok that's half of
end game yeah right like even like some
of the great martial arts scenes in
chongqi kind of approach that i don't
know this movie has incredible effects
some great fight scenes but i don't know
that we got that oh hell yeah moment in
this time we'll tell you guys i don't
know we've reached another goal for
multiverse swap we're going to have to
figure out a way to create other
variants of ourselves now i'm going to
look around okay jessica you are now you
and i might steal things you might still
think does everybody have any questions
for me in the chat
um
i can answer them as long as they're
appropriate um and if they're not
appropriate just tweet that tommy beck
told um especially feed pics
um if you have pictures oh you have any
questions about chickens i know a lot
about chickens
um
know a lot about salmon um i'm stalling
and i'm bad at okay i realize that now
do you guys wanna hear me rap uh
oh my v coach director john
any help
oh yeah i need to get ready too um here
was my favorite part about the movie
without spoiling without spoiling i
loved what they did with the illuminati
are you on my channel um no i'm just
kind of sharing with jessica i love what
they did with the illuminati i want more
of it yes um i can't wait to see sort of
like more
you know marvel factions we've got the
avengers you know and some other groups
but i want more i want i love the
illuminati i want more of that okay one
more question for john john
would you say that this is your favorite
mcu movie that came out this year
uh yes by definition
oh wait a minute
no because spider-man no way oh that was
last year that was december 2021 hey get
out of my speech little booty all right
okay
where are you guys
welcome back to the break room this is
radio shot jack tommy b and the tommy b
team we're playing all your favorite
hits and giving all our favorite
problematic takes on women children and
aliens
i don't like this guy and i'm i'm a
thanos as portrayed by a lame white guy
shaggy fan shaggy
he's not the dogs
why did you bark like
that what is that james spader down at
the end of the table it's me james
spader
this is a version this is a version of
james spader i
feel like sometimes i
travel the quandaries of man
we got the ace yeah spades we got
shagnose we got tommy b the whole family
with my sweet bodicious babe jessica i
don't know this man and i don't like it
jessica let's go to a holiday inn and
figure out our relationship tonight i
know you do i hate this version of time
sorry this is just what the variant does
okay here we go anto rondon i think i
pronounced your name right
rate the phase four movies from best to
worst
are we talking about the phase four
rotation of strippers at the barrel of
dollars
vanessa samantha jewel persephone
crystal dana holly michelle danielle
james
diane patricia monique three kims i
would put i would play i mean it's
spider-man at home i think that's like
all-time qb it's not fair
you got to put it at the top it's at the
top doctor strange comes in at number
two my number three wait what was your
number one it's spider-man no way home
it's not fair it should be everyone's
number one shanxi was like so good i
loved the fight scenes in chongqing i
love what they did in that one that one
felt so different i was into it my
number one is
uh multiverse madness
spiderman cosplay
madness is my favorite one because not
only do i
wanda
wanda
uh is in it but they wrote her so well
yes she they they wrote her they she
they just keep getting better and better
from one division to this i was like
great what else what else is there for
elizabeth wilson for me to like be in
love with her more for and then i will
say no way home
all right it's time for crank calls
we're going to call up some local
pizzerias and f with them
what is an f with them
radio show before oh you're too young
wait uh okay we don't oh we got some
more um please describe in vague terms
your favorite part
of my body that's from film juice whoa
film juice with the weird questions
always coming in i like people that's
the part where the skin comes together
yeah oh yeah you know what i like sorry
go ahead
oh you're being nice now
yeah i like uh
i like your teeth oh that's nice film
juice i've always enjoyed your knee pits
yeah um is that veg yeah i guess oh that
wasn't me that was actually very
specific oh yeah the eyelids are nice
i couldn't tell by the hand motion but
was uh producer john telling us to wrap
i think he's he's saying we got to land
this place we got to land this part but
oh sorry
we can do it together i we want to say
thank you to everybody that has watched
the show this week
uh unlike the jokes philip was making at
the beginning of the show this show this
train shows no sign of stopping no okay
we're blasting right through this
station and are gonna make it to toledo
by morning so come back join us next
week again monday's episode will be a
spoiler film we'll let these horses out
of the game yeah yeah yeah
um there's gonna be
there's gonna be cool trailers we'll
probably be talking more about avatar
yeah there's gonna be a lot going on and
then we have an extra special show next
friday what is it what is it it's going
to be our
friday the 13th
also we'll probably be drinking that's
right so if you think this show is
sloppy and unhinged yeah just you wait
and i want to say guys it's mother's day
weekend and we do appreciate all of the
mothers that watch these videos with
their kids all of our fans that are
mothers out there our own mothers i want
to say happy mother's day to my mom and
my sisters who are mothers i want to say
anyone else want to wish their mothers a
happy mother's day happy mother's day
happy birthday i know you're not
watching but happy mother's day happy
mother's day to to my mom my sister
who's mom uh my wife who is pregnant
yeah and jessica's mom who helped us on
the show this week for some game of
thrones research
i should probably think my girlfriend
who's a mom too but the baby ain't mine
that boy
but i love him like he is
she's a great mom second to me who's a
great cat all right so all you cat moms
cuban moms dog moms lizard moms and just
people who like to be called mommy we
celebrate you and we thank you for
watching everyone have a great weekend
and we will see you bye goodbye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you